we're asked to select the correct
description it looks like all the
descriptions deal with what is the limit
of f of x as we approach 6 from either
the
right hand side or from the left-hand
side so let's think about that so first
let me just do the left-hand side so the
limit
of f of x
as we approach 6 from the left hand side
what is this going to be equal to so as
we approach from the left hand side we
can see well f of 4 is a little under 2
f of five it looks like it's around
three f of five point five is it looks
like it's a lot higher
f of five point seven five even it's
just going off the chart so it looks
like this is going unbounded in the
positive direction so we could say that
this right over here is positive
infinity
and if we were to go if we were to think
about the limit
of f of x
as we approach 6 from the right side
what is this going to be well here f of
7 it's negative f of 7.5 is even more
negative f of 7
sorry f of 6.5 is even more negative not
7. f of 6.5 is even more negative f of
6.1 is even way more negative than that
f of
6.01 would be even more negative than
that so it looks like this is unbounded
in the negative direction so this is
negative infinity so let's see which of
our choices match up to that so the way
they listed it they listed the right
the the right the limit from the right
direction
first so that's this one so the limit of
f of x as x approaches 6 from values
greater than 6 we have negative infinity
so that is these two choices
these two choices say that so we're
going to rule out those two choices and
then we think about as we approach 6
from the left hand side we see that we
go to positive infinity and that is this
choice right over here so we rule out
that one and that is what we will pick